now this is an ultra wide shot what hey
guys it's max angelica and vadim and
today we are doing another blind camera
comparison with the new sony xperia one
mark iv the iphone 13 pro and the
samsung s22 ultra and the reason we're
calling this an unbiased comparison is
because max went out and he took a bunch
of photos with all three phones i think
he actually took video as well and we
have not seen them except this first one
so far now this sony costs a thousand
six hundred dollars compared to 1200 for
the s22 ultra and 9.99 to get the best
cameras in an iphone so we'll see how
good are these cameras because sony's
putting a huge emphasis on them and
what's even more interesting is that we
have the latest software updates for the
samsung we also have the beta version of
ios with the latest camera changes so
we're gonna see how these stack up so go
ahead and get your pen and paper or your
phone and play along with us we want to
know what you guessed so let us know in
the comments and i will also say i
actually voted and i looked at all these
images and videos on a 6k display very
very closely and i'll show you guys my
opinions on what i think is best so here
you guys go you guys saw the first image
we have a lot of more colored contrast
differences what do you think and what
do you like i think the one on the left
looks the best just because i feel like
i see a lot more detail when you look at
the sign it looks a lot more in focus
and sharp and the detail over here and
on him it's like much darker on the
other two i'd also have to agree with
the left one because it basically kills
it in every single way first of all it's
brought up brighter the details are more
sharp especially in the denim jacket and
just everything looks better in terms of
color
all right
that is the iphone iphone wow it's
interesting that it has more color and
contrast before it was a lot more
natural
here is the next shot i had to
crop them a little bit there's a lot of
differences here all right this one i'm
actually going with the center because i
feel like it's the most well balanced
and i do like the highlights that pop
out more it's more bright and it's nice
and sharp and i noticed that in the
trees they look very natural compared to
the one the left is very like washed out
i'm going with the right i feel like the
sign pops out a lot from the background
and
the water really pops out too with the
left one everything looks really flat
there's like barely any contrast with
the second one it looks pretty blown out
but there's so much contrast in this
right one so left one sucks the most oh
yeah yeah
oh there you go
no love for sony
yet
this is a really harsh environment sun
blazing harsh shadows oh this one's got
to be the left for sure the highlight
roll off on the faces are the most
natural whereas in the middle it's like
just just washed out bland
on the hot spot side of the face and the
the one on the right is kind of too
contrasty so left for me i agree
s22 here is our first video this is slow
motion so let's see what you guys think
center instantly it's just by far
so much more detailed in the center it
kills it
s22 ultra one thing you guys didn't
notice is that the sony is 4k 120 frames
per second compared to 4k 60 on the
others
but it doesn't really make the image
much better at least in this scenario
we have our selfie here very tough
situation oh what happened on the right
it looks so like out of focus the one on
the right that's pretty bad i'm going
with the center the one on the right
looks out of focus the one on the left
looks like really washed out and weird
the one in the center just looks the
most balanced i agree i think it looks
amazing a lot of detail there the sky
isn't blown out either it's very
impressive and it's the s22 now the sony
has a much larger sensor for the
front-facing camera
and here it might actually be out of
focus medium you might be right and
we'll see if that sensor makes a bigger
difference in low light here is the next
shot we have our first portrait photo
the one on the right looks very good
just every aspect of the portrait looks
great the colors everything and it's
also the most detailed i think right for
sure the one in the center is a little
too flat the one on the left has detail
and areas that i wouldn't want it like i
would want the focus on him yeah and
this is brighter too since you guys know
that iphone iphone it's gonna be
interesting if the iphone's gonna do the
portrait win the portrait war again but
we'll see
and we have this scenario landscape but
we're also with some subjects mixed in
wow the one on the right yeah oh my
goodness that is perfect they stand out
so much there's so much depth look at
that hair detail wow it looks perfect
it's interesting yeah so it's unanimous
for the right it's interesting that this
phone knew
that the subjects mattered too so
actually focused on them looks really
good the iphone and we have an insanely
tough portrait scenario this is just
craziness none of them are great but
which one's the best okay the one on the
left is garbage so not that one yeah um
the one that looks the most subtle is
the center the center yeah there's a
bunch of weird patches on the right
yeah it just keeps blurring the actual
random stuff so center just good job
s22 and yeah this the sony
it got some gaps and crazy blur all
around so the algorithm horrible didn't
do that good of a job now we have a zoom
shot here right around two and a half
times immediately the center for me it's
so sharp it's so clean the one on the
left is by far the worst just terrible
s22 ultra iphone looks the worst the s22
of course has a 108 megapixel um
sensor so it looked good
and we have a macro shot i'm gonna say
the center it really stands out the one
in the center has really good depth of
field but i'm actually going with the
right because i feel like it's the
sharpest the most detail well you guys
voted for the sony and the iphone is
that the first sony that's my first sony
yeah so uh the sony well let's just go
to the next shot here's another macro
shot
what
yeah the one in the center uh
actually
i like the center i like the center one
it's really bright but it pops out i'm
going really pretty i like the left
because i like the colors and you look
all the detail in these little tiny
flower buds whatever that is colors yeah
left for me you guys are in a
disagreeing mood today this is blue this
is blue right here that's i don't care
about the color you can fix that
s22 and iphone so the xperia obviously
did not focus it's actually the only
phone that does not have a macro mode
which is why if we go back in this shot
i had to step back further in order to
get anything in focus that was the
closest and this is a large object where
both of these switch to the ultrawide
that have autofocus and they go to macro
which allows them to get beautiful shots
like this
instead of not being able to get it
now we have another video very tough hdr
kind of situation it's all shot in hdr
this one on the left is so blown out
their faces are so blown out this one is
so dark but the center one has so much
detail and all the background and
everything looks really balanced yep i
agree the one in the center i like the
best the one on the left is just soft
it's blurry it's blown out the one on
the right is too dark for my liking it's
so flat look at everything in the
background
and that is the iphone
and if you guys notice it actually is a
wider camera angle both the sony and the
samsung crop in a lot when you're
shooting 4k video
and this is an insane lighting situation
it's a photo super backlit harsh shadows
this is hdr where you really need it you
can see the most detail in the center
one and all like the the shadows it's
actually brought up and you can see them
rather than the other two yep i also
like the center i like how the sun you
could actually see like some roll-off of
the color yeah and even though it's
really hdr do you see the subjects and
it doesn't look crazy fake
and that is the s22 so far
looks like samsung has had a nice
software update it's been a couple for
the cameras very good one i just
installed and now we have a video
now sony talked about their new sensor
they can shoot 4k 120 or 4k up to 60
with hdr in the video for better
exposure so let's take a look you guys
let me know what you think looks best
okay they're right it's garbage
it's the center yes the center i mean oh
look at that beautiful sunset colors and
everything's nice and sharp and brought
up and the center is the iphone once
again the iphone is looking great for
video what happened with the sony and
the sony even though they are finally
doing frame blending double exposure for
video like samsung and iphone is it is
still nowhere near the level of quality
and we have a wide portrait shot here
i'm gonna go with the right because it
has the best balance of depth of field
background blur colors everything detail
the one in the center is kind of washed
out and looks like portrait mode didn't
even work yeah the one on the left just
over killed the crap out of the portrait
mode that it looks bad and the darks are
very very dark on her face and hair
while it's brought up yeah alina pops a
lot here it's a ripe iphone that
portrait looks great and the colors pop
a lot uh you were right vadim the
sony didn't work now the hard thing is
sometimes like the iphone will tell you
hey it's not gonna work with the samsung
it was telling me that it was gonna work
and it wasn't and it's hard for these
comparisons to know what do you just cut
out but if a phone is consistently
having issues we kind of have to show at
least some of that so for this one it
looks like the one on the right still
didn't make portrait mode work but it's
also if you look closely like the detail
is lacking compared to the other ones
especially the one in the center has a
lot of detail and it's also kind of like
washed out ish like the clouds you don't
really have color just like the one on
the very left it's kind of washed out so
i'm choosing the one in the center
because the contrast the colors really
pop like if you look at the the bag like
the the color of the leather really yeah
it looks real looks real leather you
know so center for me yeah the one on
the right just everything there's no
detail and all looks weird and like
pixely and flat the one on the center is
so like dimensional there's so much yeah
it literally looks like a dslr
the quality looks like a real dslr
camera which that still looks like a
smartphone but it looks really really
good and this one looks pretty bad
s22 i have to say when i saw this image
i was shocked by how good it looks i'm
sure pros couldn't tell compared to
a lot of dslrs now i have to also
mention with the sony i took images here
multiple times and i was so nice to the
sony during the shoot i would take
double the pictures on it to make sure
stuff worked out to make sure it's fair
because it's just having issues like
this where it said it was a portrait
shot but then in reality it didn't work
out now here's the next one right here
we have an ultra wide photo with a
sunset easy
the left right yeah left instantly like
did you always the other two like look
at the detail the details and it has
less flaring too yeah less flair you see
look at that sky too beautiful yeah
s22 ultra man samsung samsung gosh that
camera's good
and we have a really tough shot here
elon really wanted to climb up wow
instantly the left yeah the left you
look at the details
look at all the texture here the uh the
colors of the face highlight roll off
it's not just smudged and blown out yeah
you guys make sure you're commenting
down below to your thoughts on some of
these images we want to hear your
opinions
the iphone looks great now we have a
portrait shot indoors
metal lighting with a lot of stuff going
on look at that the one on the right
looks so good like the the blur
everything the detail the colors this
one just hot garbage like throw that
away the one in the center is not too
bad but the one the right it really like
is the best pops out like his skin like
pops out yeah yeah
all right iphone did the best in the
scenario and sony here
not so good that's really that looks
like it's three years or so behind not
trying to be mean to the sony but wow
all right we got that bad boy there i
mean i think we know it's the center
unless if you guys disagree let me know
yeah although i wish we had this
like
that
no those colors did pop out it's kind of
like what do you prefer you know but
because i was i was honestly going to
say the right i'm going to go for it
sorry
so
the left one is just sad yeah yeah
that's bad okay so we got another one
for samsung and iphone the sony
yeah in this shot actually took three to
make sure it wasn't some air software or
something and wow no
we got a portrait shot of a vehicle this
time all right the one on the right is
just way too dark so it's not gonna cut
it the one in the center looks really
good however i noticed that most of the
car is blurred out so i'm going with the
left i think it's the best balance i
think the car in the left one definitely
pops out the most but the blurs are kind
of weird sometimes like i just noticed
up here that it completely blurred oh
yeah
it's little things like that but it does
look at this one this is completely
sharp on the little antennas yeah the
building's blurred out so both of you
said left and that is the iphone and we
have one food shot really crazy tacos
here with a ton of detail in lower light
so the one on the left is cut out
because it's just super blurry it's
super soft um and between the center and
the right i mean it's going to come down
to what's appetizing the one in the
center i like the colors i'm going to
say the one on the right i like the
colors and we have i got one for the
experience
i got one for the sony i personally like
the sony on this one and we have a
nighttime night mode shot with some zoom
this one looks so blurry everywhere
everything looks blurry i mean like one
of them just kills the others by like
five times easily the one in the center
look at all the crazy detail you could
actually read the sign river park square
right there all the colors just
all the lights you could read the dolby
imax yeah
center samsung
that looks great and we have a nighttime
ultra wide here
i'm gonna go with the one on the right
because i like there's more detail on
the bricks you can actually see the
texture and the um some of the lights
are less blown out i think um especially
at the top it looks more blown out to me
than that i mean if you look way up here
i'm going with the right
all right
experience and i feel nice and we have
an ultra wide nighttime shot this middle
one has so much flair like all over the
entire thing it looks
crazy yeah i think i'm gonna go with the
right because of that obviously the left
one yeah the left one is uh super blurry
it's a mess the one in the center has
way too much flaring the one on the
right is just by far the best super
sharp
iphone on the right and the xperia the
interesting thing is it was actually the
longest exposure
the iphone was about three seconds and
this was consistent with nighttime shots
the samsung was about five four five
seconds and the sony was about seven or
so and it still was way darker and we
have this shot of spokane falls it's
gonna be the one on the right for me uh
if you look at uh this dome of lights it
looks by far the sharpest there's a lot
more detail on the building yep you
could actually see the green color in
the washes and water power sign and the
detail
iphone at night looking great and we
have a selfie shot here i will say yep
this was an insanely tough situation
we're super dark the background is super
bright with the lights there
i mean it's going to be the left yeah
instantly left i mean by far
a samsung yeah the iphone has a bunch of
noise and the sony just looks
not good not good so that larger sensor
for the front
not really helping out here
and we have i think this is our last
video low light video performance let's
take a look
wow the one on the right is crazy
yeah look at the color on that sign and
like everything is so sharp everything's
nice and sharp it's not blowing out
lights whereas the left just looks
terrible the one on the right crazy just
kind of over contrasted
an iphone so overall iphone is
definitely the leader for video
we have this nighttime portrait with uh
night mode and portrait combined i gotta
say she really stands out in this right
photo like she really pops out from the
background but the background also looks
very like nice and saturated yeah i
think i would go with the right i think
uh overall it looks very good the center
doesn't look as good the one on the left
i think it's a little bit washed out
kind of i don't know so right pretty
good but the right ones best yeah
iphone with the portraits too and we
have a nighttime portrait selfie oh
definitely the left you guys don't like
the middle one
no the smooth skin
oh yeah it's like purple you look like a
model
hey that's not a good thing guys come on
yeah i think left
there's only one details yeah you could
actually see detail in skin and hair
everything
s22
the portraits
by far samsung is killing it with those
and we have this kind of a zoom shot
now this is where
once you guys choose i'll have to let
you guys know about something
whoa
i mean the right or no i don't know
whoa this is hard this is weird i know
right so i actually took like three or
four photos because i thought it was a
glitch
and that happened every time but this is
so blown out too this is really
difficult i mean honestly i kind of like
the center i mean it's just like ufo
sighting in your photo i like the center
because a little detail look you can see
all the like the color detail in there
it's not like insanely blown out and you
see more detail in the flag everything
even all of this is super cool and you
get this cool effect yeah
all right samsung in the center so the
samsung has that ten times tele
telephoto
iphone only has three types so the rest
is digital um the sony does have the
optical zoom camera but it's not working
it has focus issues
it was having a bunch of issues sony
said not to use it they asked not to use
it oh wow but they still sent these out
for review
uh so i think it's weird to just
completely ignore if that's a huge
selling feature so i had one of these
super zooms in here
and even though it's not zoomed in as
far just look at the image itself it
definitely sucks the most
even with the regular lens so yeah
okay we got
night mode shots now where it's really
dark center oh yeah i love how you can
see all the little stars and yeah all
the detail in the trees and yeah and
this is completely handheld quick
exposure for night mode
s22 looks
great and the sony once again took the
longest to take the image but that's
what we got
now this is an ultra wide shot what
handheld ultra wide and i leaned up
against a little post because it was my
eyes couldn't see anything but one of
these yeah
i mean i guess you'd have to go with the
left obviously the left because if
you're trying to see something you guys
want to see the tree trunk it's so
detailed though that looks really good
if only it wasn't
yeah it's just like it's unusable
because it's too dark left is the only
option yeah iphone i did not expect to
have that much of a difference the
xperia pitch black you can't see much at
all wow and then this right here with
the main lens i leaned up against uh the
little post there so the phones took
longer exposures because my handle was
steadier
well this one's so much brighter but the
sky looks really nice over here i mean
the d2 i like the one in the center by
far everything's about more detailed
everything
beautiful s22 beautiful stars right
there definitely and we have the last
one
this is set up on a tripod for a very
long exposure no shake at all oh gosh
i'm going with the center because the
one at the right is terrible all the
colors gone
left everything just like orange yeah
here you know
yeah so center samsung once again with
the star
the night star photo so the xperia does
a really good job of doing the worst of
the darks and the worst in the brights
well the stars you have a lot of stars
here
now
i have to confess again here
uh with the sony even though it doesn't
look the best either way
it will not just let you go into 30
second exposure like the other two
automatically the samsung iphone they
know hey the phone's not moving let's do
a long exposure it's on a tripod the
sony won't
so this picture actually had to go in
manual mode like you would on a real
camera set it to 30 second exposure and
then this is what i got by far better
than if you just hit the shutter button
by itself which is unfortunate that it
can't be smart enough to do that
uh but yeah that center the samsung
looks amazing so we tried giving the
sony the most fair chance but you guys
saw let us know what you thought about
it now it's time for these guys to tally
up their results i have mine that kind
of surprised me too when i looked at
everything in detail in a 6k screen
make sure you guys pause the video right
now comment down below what your score
was this is always really fun
and let's start out should we go with
angelica yeah you go first
so um iphone one for me with 17 followed
closely by the samsung 16 basically tied
and two for the sony two for the sony
man so you have iphone in first place
yeah all right vadim okay this is crazy
i got 17 for the iphone just like
angelica and i got 17 for the samsung
only one for the sony xperia
man it was a tie
hundred bucks
i tried well that's the most expensive
sixteen hundred bucks i tried tying it
now the crazy thing is sony makes the
best smartphone sensors in the iphone
all sony
but all of our cameras software we use
all
but the software just can't compete the
computational photography samsung and
apple are so far ahead and they both do
a killer job so much to fix now for me
yeah i spent a lot of time looking on a
6k screen
i had 19 for the samsung
12 for the iphone and 4 for the sony wow
so you guys had one and two i got four
because a couple times it just looked
more natural more like a dslr as far as
the colors where i chose it um and i'm
taking a closer look but still the
iphone had three times as much points as
the sony and the samsung got first place
for me
uh there you guys go so far i'll just
say i'm impressed with samsung their
software updates do you make a big
difference very good the iphone just
mostly ahead in portrait portraits if
you enjoy portraits the iphone does a
great job so there you guys go thank you
guys for watching click that circle
above to subscribe to help us reach our
goal of a million subscribers check out
one of those great videos right over
there and we'll see you guys in the next
video
[Music]